الاختلاف الوحيد
هو الأقنعة ، وإلا باريس
مدينة الفن والضوء والحب بقدر ما
كانت المتاجر مفتوحة ، والفنانين
خارج الحانات والحانات الصغيرة والمتاحف ،
هناك عنصر أساسي واحد فقط
يفتقد السياح
وما هو باريس بدون  في العام الماضي ،
جاء 50 مليون منهم من أجل
المعالم الأثرية والكاتدرائيات
والمتاحف ، حيث أنفق التاريخ 22 مليار يورو
، ومرة أخرى جعل باريس ال
دينة الأكثر زيارة في العالم هذا ال
ام ، ف
نا بها الفرنسيون والسياح الأوروبيون ال
ريبون.  لنعود إلى مستوياتنا التاريخية
قبل عام 2022.
لقد كنت مسؤولاً عن
باتو باريس لمدة سبع سنوات حتى الآن
وعرفنا أزمات فيضانات
وهجمات إرهابية
وكنا دائمًا نختار أنفسنا ولكن
في الوقت الحالي ، انخفضت معدلات إشغال الفنادق هنا في
باريس إلى 86  في المائة مما
كانت عليه قبل عام والأسوأ
هو في الطرف الأعلى من السوق
ما يسمى بفنادق القصر التي تعتمد
بالكامل تقريبًا على أعمالها
في آسيا الأمريكية  أماكن السياحة في الشرق الأوسط والشرق الأوسط
مثل فندق الريتز هنا في قبة البلازما
، فقد ظلوا ببساطة مغلقين
وسيأتي ذلك بتكلفة مذهلة على
المالية العامة لفرنسا
جيدًا ، نحن محظوظون جدًا في فرنسا للحصول
على هذا الدعم الحكومي ، إنه
فريد جدًا في العالم
أعني أن 70 من الراتب الإجمالي الذي يمثل
من صافي الخاص بك أمر فريد جدًا ومن المهم جدًا
بالنسبة لنا
أن تقول السلطات الفرنسية
إنها ستستمر في تغطية معظم
رواتب الأشخاص الذين لا يستطيعون العمل حتى
سبتمبر على الأقل  ولكن يجب أن تأتي هذه الأموال
من مكان ما حتى مع
توقع تقلص الاقتصاد الفرنسي بحلول العاشرة هذا العام ،
وربما يكون الأمر الأكثر إثارة للقلق بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين يتطلعون
إلى صناعة السياحة في فرنسا ، يجب أن
يكون هذا هو
موسم الذروة في يوم عادي من شهر يوليو
، حيث ستحصل لويزفيل على 30  إلى
40000 زائر وهذا الرقم أقل من
10000 يوميًا في الوقت
الحالي يعتمد الكثير على الوقت الذي
سيتم فيه رفع قيود السفر العالمية هذه ،
ولكن ربما يكون الأمر أكثر أهمية  لايوجد
ما إذا
كان الأشخاص على المدى الطويل سيرغبون في
العودة إلى باريس بنفس الأعداد التي
كانوا يفعلونها من قبل
ولكن ربما العكس إذا كان لديك
لقاح أو لديك علاج ،
فيجب على الناس العودة إلى حياتهم الطبيعية.
استمتع بالحياة
ميليسا بيل CNN باريس